Okay, so that proof didn't work.
Is there one that does?
Well no.
As it turns out,
the set of languages is uncountable.
We'll prove this by contradiction.
So, suppose not.
That is to say, we'll let L1, L2 be the
set of languages over an alphabet sigma.
Here, I'm giving them an enumeration.
And we'll also let X1,
X2 etc be the strings in sigma star,
we know that has an enumeration.
We are then going to build a table where
the columns correspond to the strings
in sigma star, and
the rows correspond to the languages.
In each element in
the table will put a one.
If the string is in the language and
we'll put a 0 if it is not.
Now we're going to consider a very
sneaky langauge defined as follows.
It consists of those strings Xi for
which Xi is not in the language Li.
In effect, we've taken this diagonal
here in the table and just reversed it.
Since we're assuming that the set
of languages is countable,
this language must be Lk for some k.
But is Xk in Lk or not?
You see from the table here
we've defined the row Lk such
that in every column the entry is just
the opposite of what is on the diagonal.
But this diagonal entry can't
be the opposite of itself.
If Xk is Lk, then according to the rules
for Lk, it should not be an Lk.
On the other hand, if Xk is not an Lk,
then it should be an Lk.
Another way to think
about this argument,
is to say that this language here must
be different from every row on the table
because it is different
on the diagonal element.
In any case we have a contradiction and
can conclude that this enumeration of
the languages was invalid since
the rest of our reasoning was sound.
This argument here is known as
the diagonalization trick and
we'll see it come up again later,
when we discuss undecidability.